[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de france 24 en el capítulo de hoy los
jóvenes franceses comprometidos pero no
en política analizaremos al
comportamiento de ese grupo etario de
cara a las presidenciales del próximo
año hablaremos con el autor de un libro
que hace una radiografía de los
franceses de 18 35 años y para terminar
la inmigración es un tema que suele
colarse en la pre campaña electoral
francesa les contaremos el difícil
recorrido aquí de un célebre extranjero
jóvenes franceses se movilizan un 37% de
ellos según una encuesta del año pasado
reconoce haber firmado alguna vez una
petición en línea que en la manera más
simple pero también más masiva de
compromiso sino 4 de cada 10 reconocen
haber dado alguna vez parte de su tiempo
a alguna organización como voluntario
sin embargo la participación baja cuando
hablamos de política sin ir más lejos
las regionales de este año en que un 87%
de los jóvenes de 18 o 24 años se
abstuvo fuimos al encuentro de un grupo
de activistas medioambientales en su
mayoría que está organizando unos
talleres para acercar la política
tradicional a los jóvenes estas
historias
es sábado en parís y estos jóvenes
realizan una dinámica de grupo para
conocerse y entrar en confianza van a
pasar toda la tarde juntos haciendo una
inversión en política analizando temas
como migración políticas sociales
precariedad juvenil e igualdad de género
stacy al chrome joven activista
medioambiental convencida de que la
política si puede interesar a su
generación organizó esta formación a
través de su organización pensar en
después tras hacer una dura constatación
hoy los menores de 35 años son un 40 por
ciento de la población francesa lo que
es enorme pero a nivel de nuestras
instituciones no representamos nada si
vemos por ejemplo la asamblea nacional
cuatro diputados de un total de 577
tienen menos de 30 años entre los
alcaldes sólo un 4% tiene menos de 30
años en el senado hay sólo un senador
con menos de 30 estamos en una
gerontocracia somos gobernados por los
viejos y es problemático porque eso nos
lleva a situaciones donde las ambiciones
los valores y las misiones que mueven a
la juventud son ignorados pienso en la
ecología la igualdad de género y la
justicia social necesitamos una
renovación democrática cada vez más
organizaciones se movilizan para
reinventar el voto para reinventar la
democracia participativa y dar mal lugar
al ciudadano los jóvenes se entrenan por
ejemplo en el arte de debatir hoy
discuten sobre migración
uno de ellos debe defender más
regulación de los flujos humanos y el
otro la posición contraria los
argumentos eran sólidos en ambos lados
era difícil no estar convencida por la
persona de enfrente porque tenía también
muy buenos argumentos pero es muy
interesante para hacer evolucionar
nuestro pensamiento y juliette pertenece
a una organización que propone el
servicio cívico juvenil a través del
cual los inscritos se dedican a labores
sociales como el acompañamiento de
personas solas discapacitadas o
migrantes
participar de este taller es dar un paso
más en su compromiso social
aquí estoy para participar de la
evolución de nuestra sociedad encontrar
otros jóvenes ver cómo encontrar otras
maneras de pensar distintas que las mías
es para hacer escuchar nuestra voz en
las elecciones que llegan para que
seamos escuchados para que otros jóvenes
tengan ganas de emitirse en la política
porque nos toca directamente más que a
otras personas porque es nuestro
la política en cambio no es algo cercano
para marion
este estudiante de escuela de comercio
de 24 años nunca ha votado pero su
actitud ha cambiado de carl las
presidenciales del próximo año
me cuesta tener confianza en los
políticos de hoy sin embargo el debate
de hoy con respecto a la presidencial me
parece antisocial antihumano divide la
gente y me gustaría tener las armas para
comprender lo que va a pasar y poder
tener una voz esta vez en la elección
presidencial ya les pase
tú has sido la elección que es entonces
el hernia
estos talleres terminarán con una
hecatombe democrática en enero en que
los asistentes redactaron un petitorio
que enviarán a quien resulte electo en
las presidenciales de abril
[Música]
y para conversar sobre el compromiso de
los jóvenes franceses con la política me
encuentro con stewart chau él pertenece
al instituto de sondeos viavoice y es
coautor con frederic dabi del libro la
fractura que hace una radiografía de la
juventud entre los 18 y los 30 años
buenos dias esteban bovo stuart el libro
se llama la fractura porque identifica
tres quiebres en la juventud francesa
cuáles son esos quiebres que hacen que
sea difícil catalogar la
la primera es la fractura entre los
jóvenes franceses de hoy y los de las
generaciones anteriores ya que esta
encuesta se realizó entre
1957 y 2021 la segunda es una fractura
entre los jóvenes de 2021 y la
generación anterior los jóvenes de más
edad y la tercera es una fractura dentro
de la misma juventud ya que esta
juventud de 18 a 30 años no es
monolítica se compone de un conjunto de
experiencias donde esperamos cuando
usted habla de valores cuáles son esos
que eran importantes para la generación
con las que comparó la generación actual
y los mayores los de más de 35 años por
así decirlo le dan prioridad a la
libertad mientras que los jóvenes le dan
prioridad a la igualdad esto tendrá
consecuencias grandes e importantes en
la forma en que leerán la sociedad
pues verán esta sociedad francesa como
profundamente desigual y entonces hacia
qué organismos se vuelca a la juventud
francesa y por qué no la política fútbol
acciones voces para los jóvenes
franceses la política ya no es el acto
de votar
en primer lugar creen que los actores
políticos de hoy en día son deshonestos
es un poco de adagio de todos están
podridos actualmente más del 80% de
jóvenes entre 18 y 30 años consideran
que el personal político francés es
deshonesto y el segundo elemento que
explica el hecho de que ya no crean en
la política es la impotencia que
perciben en el mundo político actual la
impotencia sobre estos jóvenes que ya no
creen que el personal político vaya a
responder a los problemas y desafíos del
mundo de mañana así que primero que todo
están comprometidos con el medio
ambiente y luego con la igualdad la
primera razón es que son unos jóvenes
que consideran que tienen todas
legitimidad para implicarse en el medio
ambiente estos actores se consideran
legítimos porque existe la idea de que
heredaron un mundo que no eligieron
necesariamente y también las
consecuencias las decisiones que no
necesariamente tomaron fueron tomadas en
el pasado así que finalmente tienen este
sentimiento de legitimidad para actuar
el segundo elemento que explica su
compromiso con el medio ambiente es el
hecho de que el compromiso con el medio
ambiente es un poco la concretización de
un tipo de compromiso propio de los
jóvenes es decir el compromiso
individual y eso es muy importante los
jóvenes ya no creen en la política
porque no creen en el principio de la
representación de la delegación del
poder y comprometerse con el medio
ambiente es recuperar el poder para uno
mismo
yo diría que el tercer elemento es que a
través del compromiso con el medio
ambiente se inventan los espacios
políticos y de compromiso lo vemos hoy
en día cuando nos comprometemos con el
medio ambiente nos comprometemos en
nuestra vida cotidiana pero también nos
comprometemos a través de otros canales
como las nuevas redes sociales que
conocemos muy bien y que son muy
influyentes
también a través de los nuevos modos de
protesta la marcha por el clima el
boicot todo esto es impulsado por los
jóvenes y como resultado transforma los
modos de compromiso político del gasto
político muchas gracias stuart shaw por
estas aclaraciones para france24 2
[Música]
en el reportaje a los jovenes debatían
sobre inmigración justamente me
encuentro frente al café les deux magots
donde el artista español pablo picasso
solía venir con sus amigos a comienzos
del siglo 20 hoy una exposición en parís
nos cuenta el difícil recorrido como
extranjero que tuvo el malagueño en
francia
es el más francés de los artistas
españoles sin embargo la relación entre
el malagueño pablo picasso y su tierra
de acogida no siempre fue fácil cuando
aún vivía en barcelona en 1901 la
galería vollard de parís le dedicó una
exposición su viaje a parís alerta a un
comisario de pirru que que le abre un
primer expediente comparable a la ficha
es el cola que hoy se señala en francia
a los terroristas
en esta carpeta se citan sus amistades
con catalanes afincados en bombas como
prueba de su carácter anarquista pero
también las temáticas oscuras
inhabituales de sus cuadros
como
como ser extranjera en una francia que
está en medio de una ola de xenofobia
influye en la trayectoria y obra de tu
caso es esa es la persona que yo me puse
es una pregunta que tiene actualidad hoy
porque estamos en un periodo electoral y
la cuestión de la identidad de los
migrantes está por todos lados
picasso muestra justamente como el
aporte de las diversas culturas es
positivo para francia con cumbia kumbia
el apodo criolla de las cosas y positiva
durante la primera guerra picazo es un
extranjero y se lo hacen notar
con un extranjero durante las guerras
necesita una autorización para moverse
de una ciudad a la otra es lo que se
llama un salvoconducto y ahí estamos en
1918 y él pide ir de múnich a biarritz
para su luna de miel
durante la segunda guerra picasso se ha
hecho un nombre en europa del este y
nueva york gracias a los mercaderes de
artecam tyler y stein es además un
multimillonario comprometido con la
república española y el antifascismo sin
embargo francia le deniega a su pedido
de nacionalidad en 1940 emil se valía el
funcionario cargo saca a la luz el
informe de 1901 y junto a otras pruebas
justifica el rechazo
necesitaba la ciudadanía francesa en un
momento preciso porque tenía miedo por
su vida porque en españa habían matado a
garcía lorca en
1936 como víctima expiatoria del
fascismo tenía miedo pero creo que nunca
necesitó ser francés y en ese momento
necesitaba tener derechos tras la
liberación se une al partido comunista
su verdadera patria según la exposición
y dona 10 cuadros a los museos franceses
el gobierno le concede entonces una
tarjeta de residente privilegiado la
reconciliación quede impresa a los
cuadros hoy gran parte del patrimonio
del artista pertenece a francia que
levantó un museo para albergarlo gracias
a la ley de sucesión del escritor y
ministro de cultura andrés algo los
herederos del español que no dejó
testamento pagan cada cierto tiempo los
derechos de sucesión en obras
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
enfocó muchas gracias por su compañía y
hasta una próxima por las pantallas de
64 o en france 24 punto com